trois nouveaux invités sur ce plateau et
on parle de beatbox enfin et oui donc
parce que le premier championnat
européen va avoir lieu dans les Yveline
trois dates trois salles donc pour en
parler ce soir n nous recevons trois
invités et voilà donc Christophe MAF
directeur du café de la plage à morpa
Mik SP vous êtes organisateur de la Cup
bitbox présentateur aussi présentateur
organisateur et à côté de moi Py vous
êtes vous-même beatboxer beatboxer voilà
alors déjà on a envie de se demander
alors le beatbox bah qu'est-ce que c'est
et je pense que le mieux c'est de
regarder un
[Musique]
[Rires]
extraitidée
donc Christophe vous êtes l'un des
représentants donc des trois structures
qui organisent donc ce championnat euh
dites-nous quel est le principe alors le
principe c'est
euh une façon on va dire un petit peu à
la Coupe Davis de se retrouver de
retrouver la grande famille des
beatboxeurs et particulièrement pour la
première fois la grande famille EUR PN
plus plus he puisqu'on a des Hongrois
des Russes qui vont participer à 8 pays
tout à fait quatre représentants de
chaque pays l'idée était de continuer un
petit peu de façon exponentielle le
travail qu'on fait depuis 5 années
maintenant sur morpa avec avec mypone et
Kim autour du beatbox voilà on est passé
de Cup enfin de de Battle individuel on
va dire jusqu'à des rencontres
maintenant par équipe avec des
représentants de pays voilà donc h pays
à chaque chaque fois donc qure membres
par équipe c'est ça et donc au final
deux pays s'affrontent c'est un peu une
coupe des nations voilà tout à fait
principe coupe des vis Coupe des nations
coupe de la ligue
ou et alors max donc vous allez
présenter cette ce championnat du coup
la langue va-être l'anglais ou fris ça
va être un mélange des deux on va dire
je parle un petit peu anglais
logiquement je devrais être accompagné
d'un MC anglais qui va m'aider pour
l'anglais sinon ça sera en français
d'acc ce sera en beatbox c'est une
langue surtout en beatbox c'est une
langue universelle le beatbox c'est VI
et quelles sont les les règles
globalement pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas alors les règles bah ça va être
assez basique on va dire donc on a deux
équipes qui vont se rencontrer donc il y
aura un buzzer au milieu chaque équipe
passera aura 4 minutes au total
chacune ils pourront passer soit en solo
soit par équipe par deux par trois ou
par quatre c'est qui décideront donc ça
sera un battle assez technique et donc
une équipe passera commenera beatboxer
appuiera sur le buzz ce qui arrêtera
lete le compteur et l'autre équipe
enchaînera et donc ensuite on a un jury
international qui désignera le le
gagnant du Battle parce que l'idée c'est
d'obtenir le plus de points exactement à
B chaque donc il y a des critères
justement alors quels sont les les
critères pour obtenir ces points alors
les critères ça par contre ça reste un
changer un peu comme dans tous les
battles critèrees de technique donc la
technicité sera sera un critère de de
jugement la technicité euh
l'originalité la propreté aussi des sons
que les sons soient jolis à entendre qui
ressemblent le plus possible à des TR
instruments de musique euh à mon avis
alors ensuite ça c'est les trois
critères principaux je crois qu'il y
aura aussi comme critère la présence
scénique qui est très important et voilà
d'accord donc en fait obtenir un maximum
de points en pensant à tous ces critères
pe ce qui veut dire qu'il y a quand même
c'est très stratégique parce que chaque
équipe peut décider de faire des solos
ou des des équipes ou que des équipes
bien sûrobjectif l'objectif c'est de
gagner à la fin donc peut-être que ça
sera plus payant de passer en équipe
parce qu'à deux on peut faire plus de
choses mais tout seul on peut plus
impressionner en montrant qu'on est
capable de faire plus de choses qu'on
est capable de faire plein de choses
même tout seul quoi d'accord vous pouvez
peut-être tous les deux nous faire une
petite démo là tout de suite en
liveout en plus tu prends le tien tu
prends le tien aussi
[Musique]
allons-y
merci à vous pour cette petite démo en
plateau ça marche aussi en voiture on
pas d'autadio
derrière voiture ça marche bien tout le
temps dites-moi Py est-ce que quand on
prépare une battle bah justement est-ce
qu'on prépare ou est-ce que finalement
c'est que de l'impro total bah ça dépend
les personnes ça dépend les beatboxur il
y en a qui vont préparer et il y en a
qui vont être en freestyle en freestyle
il va écouter ce qu'il va faire son
adversaire il va reproduire la même
chose peut-être en mieux et après
peut-être en moins bien
comment par exemple vous préparez vous
travaillez bah généralement comme on
tous les jours on beatbox donc on
travaille tous les jours limite tous les
jours le matin on réveille ouais ouais
sous la douche on va dire c'est vrai que
s la douche non pas en rasant ça
difficile c'est difficile mais euh les
bonne idée d'urélia mais c'est vrai
qu'on bat box t les jour en voiture
comme on disait tout à l'heure donc mais
après quand on a un
battle soit on va préparer soit c'est
vraiment feeling on sent Press et ça
dépend notre humeur si on est chaud si
on est pas chaud ou pas et à quoi on
reconnaît une belle performance bah déjà
le public si le public réagit à notre
sonorité si vraiment le public réagit et
que ça fait vraiment un boucan ça veut
dire que ça c'était bon quoi donc il y
aura des maximum de points estce qu'
vous arrive de vous dire mais ça je veux
lui il l'a fait mais moi aussi je veux
le faire exactement ben c'est pour ça
qu' ouais bien sûr bien sûr il faut
savoir que le beatbox c'est aussi un
très grand partage on est une très
grande famille en Europe en France on se
connaît vraiment bien et donc dès qu'il
y a un nouveau beatboxeer qui sort un
nouveau bruit il y a l'autre qui essaent
de faire la même chose de le mettre à sa
sauce et tout enfin voilà question
communauté les équipes du café de la
plage ce sont mis au beatbox pas toutes
parti oui vous ne reviendrez sur ce
plateau qu'uniquement une fois que vous
maîtriserez un petit peu le beatbox je
vous envoie on va rappeler les dates
puisque c'est trois dates sur trois
structures différentes le 17 donc ça va
se passer à mont-elajolie au Centre
d'Action Culturelle George brassins le
18 c'est au café de la plage donc ce
seront les demi-finales en l'occurrence
et également la clé saint-gerain la
finale voilà et donc toutes les infos
sur le site de la CAP beatbox merci à
tous les trois merci Aurélien on se
quitte en musique on se retrouve demain
18h pour une nouvelle édition du 78 on
se quitte donc en musique pour l'instant
avec un autre artiste c'est été il sera
le 1er juin à Saint-Germain en lait le
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aue un cou de rien si fort pourtant la
bande
son de ta
vie B
retrouaill comme on envoit guerre plus
même rangain 20 ans
après les regrets la douleur ça va vu de
près le bonheur c'est quoi le bon
refrain au bon moment la bon son de
Cé un coup de rien si fort pourtant la B
de son
de de ta vie
[Musique]